[Music]
on this Sunday night the consequences of
a celebration turned sour The Fallout
from the Mayhem at Toronto's Festival
Eritrea
with police now under scrutiny
more bridges in Crimea bombed Ukraine's
new attacks and the latest War crime
Russia is accused of
the fight for the right to choose in
Texas the state doesn't care about the
lives of their constituents the battle
between judges and the potential
punishments for doctors who perform
abortions
and a milestone with fond military
memories because we wanted to see the
world a second World War veterans flight
path with the Royal Canadian Air Force
global national with far and Esser
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us outrage is
mounting in Canada's largest city in the
wake of a community celebration that
turned violent
chaos erupted yesterday when protesters
stormed the Eritrean Festival in Toronto
it's intended to be a cultural
celebration of the African nation but
experts say the protesters eritreans
themselves came out to demonstrate
against the current government as Amar
Khan explains the city has now cut the
festival short
[Music]
chaos ensuing
as protesters tear down fences and tents
at Festival Eritrea in Toronto
on Saturday morning violence breaking
out sending nine people to the hospital
including one who was stabbed and
critically injured the attack was
totally
uh unprecedented and improvised members
of Toronto is a retrained Community left
stunned and shocked it's a kind of
vandalism this is what they did is the
vandalism it is a senseless I I call it
it's a senseless disturbance located in
Northeast Africa and once a part of
Ethiopia in 1993 Eritrea became its own
country now home to more than 3.5
million people
the festival has taken place in Toronto
for 25 years many of those at Earls
Court Park an expert on African history
says Those Who frequent the festival are
supporters of the government and
protesters against this is not the first
time that there have been quoted or
opposition to it around the world those
opposing it are eritreans who bled the
unbruttled tyranny in the country the
violence led the city of Toronto to
revoke the festival's license
essentially canceling it on Sunday a
heavy police presence and city of
Toronto security as the tents came down
many frustrated at the city's decision
the victim is being re-victimized by
revoking the license tyria cargo says
the Eritrean communities met with
Toronto police calling for security for
several weeks including as late as this
week what went wrong it's still to be
accounted Toronto police say they
deployed officers throughout the event
and sent in reinforcements once the
violence broke out they added they are
continuing to investigate the incident
the Eritrean Community is supposed to
host a Gala event tonight where
protesters say they will be present
kiriakako says the police and City need
to do better the threat is unacceptable
the potential violence it's unacceptable
this year's fast is over ending on a
dark note and this community that's
familiar with hardship will now have to
wait another year to celebrate its
culture together Amar Khan Global News
Toronto
it has been an unprecedented summer for
wildfires across Canada especially in
British Columbia in the past 24 hours
alone more than 30 new fires have begun
in the province firefighters are using
every tool at their disposal and this
weekend that includes starting fires
Alyssa Carpenter explains
we don't want to be evacuate in case it
gets close to town we don't want to lose
power
for Jim Hildebrandt and his neighbors
living in and around Sparwood BC fire
has become a part of the summer season
the Ladner Creek Fire has been burning
for weeks while more than 125
firefighters work night and day to try
and keep it at Bay
they're doing control burns to uh so
they won't get the power line and uh
I didn't stop it from spreading in town
so at least we're not going to lose our
power here hopefully but it's tender dry
and just as residents thought
firefighters were getting the upper hand
another flare-up over the weekend we
actually returned from vacation and had
seen a spark up we actually lived down
close to where some of the fires are
burning on White Birch near the rec
center there's a lot of dead stuff on
the Mountainside and they gotta have to
get rid of it somehow it's Mother Nature
doing his job
the fire situation in this small BC
Community playing out right across
British Columbia right now there are
more than 360 wildfires burning in the
province that includes 32 new fires in
the past 24 hours for Wildfire BC it's a
fine Balancing Act juggling the
resources needed to fight active fires
bringing in resources from other parts
of Canada while also employing
prevention and suppression techniques
the BC Wildfire service posting videos
to its YouTube channel this weekend
showing firefighters conducting several
planned ignitions in various parts of
the province the goal is to get rid of
what fuels the fire that drive agitation
by burning it away in a planned and
controlled fashion it can be
counter-intuitive for folks because
you're introducing fire to fire it says
several successful planned ignitions
have taken place with more to come this
week while they are one effective tool
there are a number of other factors
including the forecast that go into
decide deciding whether that's the best
way to fight an active fire as for this
fire near Sparwood the mayor is betting
on Mother Nature the only thing that's
really going to put it out is snow
um so uh we'll start seeing snow here in
the next up top potentially in the next
six to eight weeks Alyssa Carpenter
Global News
a major fire has erupted at a commercial
lumber yard in Winnipeg firefighters
first responded overnight calling for
more help as the Flames grew several
homes in the area were evacuated as a
precaution people are now back home but
they're being told to keep their doors
and windows closed due to air quality
concerns on firefighters suffered minor
injuries and was treated at the scene
there are no reports of any other
injuries from fire to water at least
three people have been killed in
Slovenia as the country Works to recover
from devastating floods
A month's worth of rain hammered
two-thirds of the country on Friday the
mayor of this Northern settlement nearly
wiped out by the floods says it's an
enormous loss that has ruined us while
the cleanup is underway roads have been
washed out building swamped and bridges
broken throughout the country slovenia's
prime minister says this is the
country's worst natural disaster the
government has earmarked 10 million
euros for humanitarian Aid
a passenger train has derailed in
southern Pakistan killing at least 30
people and injuring at least 100 others
the train was on a cross-country trip
carrying about a thousand people when
several cars came off the tracks
emergency crews are working to free
survivors from the wreckage
investigators are still trying to figure
out what caused the derailment but say
the train was traveling at a normal
speed accidents are common on Pakistan's
decaying and outdated rail system
it's deadline day in Niger West African
neighbors are giving that military Junta
until today to reinstate democratically
elected president Muhammad bazoom if it
doesn't it could face a military
intervention as of now coup leaders
haven't budged
[Music]
some people took to the streets of the
country's capital today to voice their
support for the coup
Ottawa is condemning it and has now
suspended direct financial aid to
niger's government between 2021 and 2022
Canada provided more than 2.7 million
dollars to the country
retaliatory attacks against Russian
aggression appear to be ramping up two
Bridges connecting Russian occupied
areas of Ukraine with Crimea have been
damaged after an apparent missile attack
it marks Ukraine's latest attempt to
disrupt Russian supply lines and
military operations in Crimea and the
Black Sea and as Redmond Shannon reports
Keith is trying to shore up more
international support against Russia's
full-scale invasion
explosions at two of the bridges
connecting Russian annexed Crimea with
the other russian-held parts of Ukraine
the second attack on one of the bridges
in six weeks the local russian-backed
Governor says damage to the important
supply lines were caused by Ukraine's
nato-supplied Storm Shadow missiles
like this one President Vladimir
zielenski signing one of the storm
Shadows provided by France note the
Eiffel Tower on top of Ukraine's Trident
symbol
zelenski posthumously honoring an Air
Force member on the country's Air Force
day and praising service members for
their efforts
earlier this week he said training on
Western supplied F-16 fighter jets will
start this month
zelenski said this overnight airstrike
on a blood transfusion Center is a war
crime it killed two people on a night
when Ukraine says it shot down 57 of
Russia's 70 missile and drone attacks
the volley an apparent retaliation for
Ukraine striking against a Russian Navy
ship and a tanker in the Black Sea in
recent days Russia says it also
intercepted another drone aimed at
Moscow Sunday
and it accuses Ukraine of hitting a
university in Russian occupied Donetsk
with cluster bombs Global News cannot
verify those claims in Saudi Arabia on
the weekend the Ukraine peace conference
gathered 40 Nations together excluding
Russia but including the kremlin's
hugely influential Ally China so what
they're doing is they are trying to flip
more neutral countries and we saw China
participate which is a big deal the
Jetta meeting ended with participants
agreeing on more talks zelenski hopes
for a formal Summit later in the year
but it's going to take a lot of time and
I think the Ukrainian government is
doing you know hard diplomatic work and
bringing people together who don't agree
the territorial Integrity of Ukraine is
key to any peace plan and on that the
two sides remain as far apart as ever
Redmond Shannon Global News London
making a rare exception coming up why a
new ruling on the strict abortion ban in
Texas likely won't hold
and how the next provincial election in
this country could reverse the blue Tory
wave
[Music]
a painful back and forth battle is
underway over abortion rights in Texas a
judge has ruled the state's abortion ban
is too restrictive for women with
serious pregnancy complications but just
as the temporary injunction was put in
place it was blocked by an appeal
the state doesn't care about the lives
of their constituents less than three
weeks after Amanda zarowaski uttered
those words judge Jessica magrum agreed
there needs to be an exception to the
abortion laws in Texas in her ruling
magrum said the court finds that there
is uncertainty regarding whether the
medical exception to Texas's abortion
bans permits a physician to provide
abortion care wherein the physician's
good faith judgment and in consultation
with the pregnant person a pregnant
person has a physical emergent medical
condition but just as quickly as the
injunction went into place it was
blocked by an appeal to the Texas
Supreme Court in a statement the
Attorney General's office called it
ineffective adding the status quo
remains in effect Millions
[Music]
but
not
any more in Texas
just over a year ago abortion was banned
in Texas with very few exceptions it's
one of 15 states that do not allow the
procedure for fetal anomalies doctors
who perform abortions risk life in
prison and fines of up to one hundred
thousand dollars the challenge filed in
March aimed to force Clarity on
exemptions under the strictest law in
the U.S
oh man Samantha Casiano one of 13 women
who sued the state became visibly
distressed as she testified she'd had to
carry her child Halo until she went into
labor despite the baby's fatal condition
I had to watch my babies
zarowaski says reliving her pain
publicly was worth the outcome but it's
an outcome that may not stick in a state
where most abortion providers have
already closed their doors
[Music]
I had expect plenty of mud slinging as
Manitoba conservatives fight to hang on
in a fall election
[Music]
it's the middle of summer but political
pundits are already looking ahead to the
fall when Canada's next provincial
election is set to happen manitobans
head to the polls October 3rd Premier
Heather Stephenson is looking to keep
her conservatives in power for a third
term and despite a long Tory winning
streak as Eric Sorensen explains
Stephenson is facing a tough fight
since taking over as Manitoba's
conservative Premier it's been a bumpy
ride for Heather Stephenson polls showed
manitobans disapproved of her handling
of the pandemic more recently she's been
under Fire from protesters and others
for the province's decision not to fund
the search of a landfill for missing
persons I have to protect all manitobans
throughout this including those that
would be asked to go into those
landfills that and issues such as health
care have put stefanson on the defensive
against her main Challenger the ndp's
wab canoe with the next election just
eight weeks away I think it's time that
you have a provincial government you can
be proud of again polls show the two
parties are close but the conservatives
Trail in Winnipeg where most
Battleground seats are fought they
really have to work harder on getting
Winnipeg voters on their side if they
want to save power in the in the
legislature conservative parties have
done well in provinces across the
country ever since Justin Trudeau's
Federal liberals were elected since 2015
voters in seven provinces have changed
from left of center to conservative
leaning government Alberta Manitoba
Ontario Quebec and the three Maritime
Provinces in all 13 elections including
six conservative governments re-elected
and no defeats among provincial premiers
Saskatchewan Scott Moe and Nova scotia's
Tim Houston have the highest approval
rating in the most recent Angus Reed
survey but trailing the pack is Heather
Stephenson of Manitoba an approval of
just 25 percent sometimes you're going
to have a situation where an electorate
wants to Zig a certain way federally and
zag a certain way provincially but also
you can have an electorate that simply
tired of the government of the day
stefenson can expect to be in the
crosshairs of both the Liberals led by
dougold Lamont and canoes NDP Heather
Stephenson can't run on the disaster in
the Healthcare System right now
Stephenson told Global's clay young
she's ready for what's coming I think we
need to have thick skin in in politics
and it's certainly not going to change
anything that that we're going to do to
get out there and fight hard for
manitobans Christopher Adams expects a
mudslinging campaign I think it will be
a tough campaign I think uh similar to
what we saw in Alberta I think we'll see
some pretty heavy messaging coming up
here in Manitoba no conservative
provincial government in the country has
lost in the last eight years Heather
steffensen's Manitoba PCS will have a
fight on their hands not to become the
first Eric Sorensen Global News
next a second world war vet vetted for
her work and a milestone birthday
heartbreak for Team USA at the Women's
World Cup it lost to Sweden in the round
of 16 teams the Americans had dominated
every static except the score needing
penalty kicks after a nil nil draw the
game ended dramatically when the swedes
game-winning shot appeared to be saved
before video review showed the ball
crossed the line by just millimeters
this is the earliest the U.S women's
national team has ever been eliminated
from the World Cup
most of us experienced the second world
war through photographs that's also the
case for Yvonne Wildman the difference
is she was actually there taking
photographs as part of her job serving
her country one of many women working
for the Royal Canadian Air Force as
Brodie Radcliffe reports she's
celebrating a very special Milestone
with a lot of memories
so you can become what you want to
if you
really push it it was an important week
for Yvonne Wildman celebrating her 100th
birthday
[Music]
I'm surprised Yvonne grew up with seven
siblings all of whom were Boys by the
time she was 19 she joined the Royal
Canadian Air Force my girlfriend and I
decided to
because we wanted to
see the world like her dad she was
interested in engines but her dream of
working on Motors was stalled mechanics
required a grade 10 certificate Yvonne
only finished grade eight well I went
and did photo
because they wouldn't let me go into
water
I wanted to after six months of basic
training she was sent to Vulcan Alberta
where she helped the bomber Pilots train
although she admits the first flight she
was on made her queasy well I couldn't
have cared of that plane had crashed
when the war was over Yvonne and the
rest of the rcaf women's division were
let go she returned home got married and
had seven children not just telling her
family about her experiences during the
war but showing them
a part of my life and I do again as for
her secret to a long life her lips are
sealed do you have any secrets
nope no secrets at all then well if I
did I wouldn't tell you
Brodie Radcliffe Global News Saskatoon
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm calling Christy
tonight's your Canada is Vancouver's
45th annual Pride Parade
okay
yeah a surprise
[Music]
the theme for this year's Festival is
reconnect focusing on the Vancouver
Pride society's commitment to amplify
marginalized Community Voices and the
parade is also on a new expanded route
for greater accessibility allowing
thousands to get together to have fun
during BC's long weekend thanks for
watching Farm Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great night
thank you
[Music]